these guys hate black people's and gays
they watch Empire just a smaller case so
can we go back in time it's like when
your student doesn't put in this paper
and you're like where's your paper
here's like my dog hate it couldn't have
happened possible did it nah let's be
real and that's how I feel about this
story the hole in the story and the
script was stinky oh and I heard the
story I'm like nothing about this reeks
of tiki torches yo okay nothing even the
people of Chicago like we don't believe
this [ __ ] what do they know they
said you know you know nobody in this
Chicago coldest weather is going to
subway at 2:00 a.m. okay and who listen
they'll go out there for some Burger
King you know I'm saying have it your
way
but not for subway eat fresh why cuz at
2:00 a.m. it's it kind of fresh hmm you
mean to tell me that two white
supremacist attacked you in downtown
Chicago are two in the morning
[ __ ] word that's your story huh
Chicago yo brother just last week I was
in the heart of Ethiopia and two
Klansmen jumped me yeah yeah believe him
yeah they came in on a flying burning
cross and they were yelling Heil Hitler
I don't make no sense oh please believe
him know when the first story broke out
they were looking at you know for two
white supremacist and then they shifted
their attention the police to two
African brothers and I'm like no no no
you're not gonna pin this on us
[Music]
[Applause]
they went back to their kitchen I can my
brothers find a new way to Prince's from
now on you are going to find a gay black
man and you are going to punch him in
the face okay and then you're going to
yeah this is Makkah country this is my
country
yeah listen Republicans you guys might
hate Africans with your slogan sounds
like it's from what Conda doesn't it
matter forever
and the only people that I know that
same Agha is Jamaican [ __ ] look
at my god y'all skinny may be making
America great again means making it
skinny because you a white supremacist
recognized him off the street at 2:00 in
the morning they're like hey your night
[ __ ] [ __ ] from these guys hate black
people's and games they wash Empire
[Applause]
now I don't want to root for the white
man but my spider-sense
black people are quick to believe that
these guys recognized just a smaller
idealist actor yet why people cannot
tell the difference between Samuel
Jackson and Laurence Fishburne Whoopi
Goldberg or me what do you think they
recognize that d-list celebrity at 2:00
in the morning white supremacist who
think all [ __ ] are the same and [ __ ]
all should die you think you recognize -
just just say small a juicy small that
juicy small egg just be smaller listen
maybe it's at times a change maybe white
supremacists are so progressive that now
they're culturally sensitive who you
know it's apparently they threw bleach
on what kind of white supremacist is
just like they're too dark [ __ ] swag
now you will take off those Nike shoes
we don't wear those anymore no black
people are too much busy doing that to
themselves we bid skip and if you don't
know they found out - the white
supremacist bought all of their weapons
from a hood black owned store called the
crafty beaver because you know when
you're gonna commit hate crimes you
might as well support black businesses
yeah we hate blacks but we buy black
wipe our this story was so unbelievable
that even the people of Chicago were
like we believe the police we believe
the pony the Chicago PD and what really
a positive would really I hate about
this [ __ ] and why he's a jackass to me
is that if next time someone is actually
gonna get a hate crime from the gay the
LGBTQ community then we're gonna be like
you are you small laying you know I mean
like now people are gonna be scared of
just you know boys or the police for a
crime same way that people are scared to
report it makes us look bad
he looks bad hey but he looks bad
Malcolm X says it best is I'm for
justice for everyone it doesn't matter
who it's for or against
just for justice and I think that's the
mandate so me when I saw this story I
didn't think of it as a black or a white
thing white supremacist this and what I
saw was a story that was unbelievable
that that's set to set people back and
that put people in jeopardy right cuz
imagine if he had named victims or
suspects and we would have derailed
their lives because we perceive them as
being guilty just because Jesse came
forward well you know I think the
positive from this whole thing is that
maybe politicians and all these people
who got on their [ __ ] soapbox to be
like yeah you know Jesse we're with you
and white supremacy and Donald Trump
have to do better than this and that
maybe you guys are gonna wait to hear
the facts of a story before you come
forward and ready to condemn someone and
this goes for the people on the other
side of the aisle too who are ready to
condemn black people based off minimal
information I think the biggest element
of this story that people miss is that
hey we don't need facts
we got feelings we hit the other side
we're gonna believe anyone on our side I
said people lied people live for the
soil and self-interest wait why would
anyone make up a rape claim because they
felt shame because they felt this why
would anyone make up a hate crime
because they want to make money because
they want to raise their profile because
it's possible people fake things people
lie further their own benefit up but you
know what Jesse smell it I feel bad you
know he's a gay black man and that's a
lot of struggle in one person but part
of me didn't believe that he was gay
serious cuz I as a individual who's
faced racism homophobia he's gone
through the process of living in the
closet for 10 years and having to lie to
all the people this couldn't make up one
good
[Laughter]
like [ __ ] check your memory bank you
got some action right son well that's a
weird this was the most unpleasant story
and I read it and I immediately newest
fiction because I'm like there's just
too much sauce on it it's like hate
isn't that complex unless its aesthetic
it's not that crazy
they put a noose around your neck they
threw bleach on you they did all this
everything that they was waiting with a
noose and bleach in the cold a sweater
in downtown Chicago for you to pass and
be there so big-ass news [ __ ] you know
all the people saying nope he's being
set up
listen why is he being said why is he
being set up because some people are
saying that the he was about to buy NBC
boy if you don't you know I'm feeling
that somewhere out there during all this
Black History Month craziness someone is
benefiting from all this chaos let's
leave Lisa and this this this that who
would you say is benefiting us it's
great content Toby you're like am I just
here right now na boo boo that's it for
today's you know toast what you guys
think you do you guys believe he's still
innocent are you guys that nutty I doubt
it
tell us what you guys think we want to
hear your thoughts leave your comments
below
[Music]
[Applause]